I have had a body, lots of body aches possibly long COVID and have been on
predisone. Is there something else I could use? I had been using the clear
inflame, but that just wasn't enough. Make sure you're running the COVID
programs on the right machine. So I do have a video on the website about
long COVID as well. I'll try to tomorrow, I'll try to remember to put it up on the
member site. It might be better on the member site, so the FDA doesn't
connect to me about that video too. And that will help too. Nothing is going to
decrease inflammation as fast as predisone. I'll tell you that. So the other thing
that you could use for that has helped a lot of people is a product called
Limitless. Limitless is a beta-lin. It's a patented beta-lin product, which is the
most highly anti-inflammatory substance that you can get without a
medic without a prescription. It's called Limitless. It comes in a box of 20 or
30 of you or something like that. We have another store Limitless. That might
help as well. We've seen people that were... I haven't personally seen anybody at
Predisone, but I've seen people taking 20 tylidol a day go and live in this and go on
and get off of their ad-bill or tailbone.